unruly passengers making national
headlines the most recent case a man
duct taped to his seat after allegedly
assaulting flight attendants on a flight
yeah so if you fly a lot you may have
witnessed some of these things with the
mass mandate extending now through
january more of these incidents could be
expected and sally jeremiah is live at
mccarran airport with what travelers are
seeing and some of the chaos on these
flights sally
many travelers i spoke with say they
have seen these disruptive videos on
social media but have yet to see an
extreme case while flying in and out of
mccarran travelers tell me they seem
most complying when it comes to wearing
a mask
chances are you saw this viral video and
people are still talking about it and
it's not the only one to make headlines
over the past year many incidents on
airplanes captured on phones most of it
is
has been in the media travel agent abby
lagman says she is glad to see travelers
in and out of mccarran did not make a
headline i hear the frustrations but i
you know it just it's it's frustrating
i'm sure for all of us right especially
when it comes to mass but lagman says it
is what we need to do right now to keep
traveling safely one of those things
that we just have to do you know the
airlines require them besides finding
the best destinations and deals for her
clients she also stresses the rules of
flying paul rosenberg just took his
first trip this year and agrees i flew
from vegas to new york
and then from new york to croatia
rosenberg says passengers appear to be
compliant on his flights and reminds
other travelers to respect the flight
crew if you're going to fly there's
rules
and if you're not willing to comply with
the rules then you probably shouldn't
get on the airplane
out here live according to the faa since
the beginning of the year there have
been about 3 900 unruly reports with
nearly 3 000 refusing to wear a mask for
now reporting live in mccarran airport
sally jaramillo 8 news now